so apparently apple to reinstate parlor
the app at center of online speech
debate this is a wall street journal
story
uh they're planning on putting it back
on their apple remove parlor from its
app store in january citing
objectionable content in a letter to
senator mike lee of utah and
representative ken
buck of colorado apple said monday that
a reverse revised version of the app uh
parlor app with improved content
moderation would be approved to be
released so to apple users
et cetera okay a big part of it was
because of what happened in capitol
building
january 6. anyways what do you think
about parlor getting back on apple and
apple reinstating them
good about time and it's great that we
have other choices and
parlor would let people
say things that the censors at facebook
and twitter are now banning i mean
discussions about
vaccines and whether we need all these
masks and
push back on all sorts of issues that
ought to be part of the public debate
and yes there was a lot of nasty stuff
on parlor
prior to them being kicked off but the
riot at the capitol wasn't from
parlor most of those people learned
about it from facebook
to be fair it was probably a higher
percentage of hate
on parlor and i don't know what this new
moderating system is going to be
but i'm glad they're back and my stuff
is on parlor your stuff is on parlor
yeah
very so i've had a few pieces that
facebook and youtube wouldn't
run and i'm glad that parlor will have
you ever been on parlor i've never been
on parliament really
no why not be honest with you there's so
many platforms right now i can't even
keep up with them
are you more likely to go on parlor or
tick tock
i like having everybody from
all sides hear the message rather than
just one side
so um good point yeah if we're talking
to the
i know who i'm talking to i would much
rather talk to
opposition because what is the what is
the true
you know the one thing with trump you
hate them or love them say whatever you
want to say about the guy if there was
an opportunity to go out there and
interview in a heated
like i'm talking about people that were
going to trash him he showed up
so and how many people would do that how
many how obama showed up on bill
o'reilly one time
never happened again when's the last
time hillary clinton went on fox news
when's the last time bill clinton on fox
news you don't see that too often and
you don't even see it too many times of
republicans like if you wonder
like some guys being invited on fox even
a lot of republicans not invited on fox
going on cnn or msnbc they don't go on
it right
trump's like if i'm going to get elected
i got to meet the opposition
i think too many politicians are just
talking to their base and they're
getting you excited because people
support them but you ain't converting
anybody
you gotta trump's a fighter he enjoys a
good fight so he'll go anywhere
trump's a converter biden's not a
converter oh i don't know if trump's a
converter 100
trump's a converter but obama's a
converter uh a bill clinton's a
converter
reagan's a converter these are
converters bush seniors not a converter
uh president bush is not a converter uh
this is not a republican or democratic
thing i'm not i'm not talking
able to maybe convince some people yeah
if if i'm
able to get him his audience to convert
you got 44 42
right 44 is going to vote democrat no
matter what 42 is going to repo
vote republican no matter what you got
the race is really what that additional
yeah that you're dealing with and out of
the 14 there's going to be a percentage
that no matter what's going to vote what
libertarian take that two out so now
you're dealing with maybe three maybe
three maybe they play their cards
dealing with 10 or 12 percent so if i
can win and convert a bit of john
yeah and if i can convert a bit of
independent now i'm winning so
i don't think you're converting anybody
on parlor i think you're converting on
tick-tock you got to give it up
though i'm not even on tick-tock i've
done two posts on tick tock i got a
challenge maybe you and i do a dance
maybe even john saucer shows up we do
do a dance i'll tell you we're talking
about getting on tickets you've been on
tick tock yet
no isn't it all they're all super short
it is
it's like vine on steroids right if you
were gonna hit a dance moment i'm not a
singer or dancer if you were gonna dance
what dance move would you bust out on
tick tock
i have to pass on that i cannot think of
a good idea
dance mover too but you got to give a
shout out even though he's a quote
unquote economic idiot
bernie sanders will go on fox news and
try to convert he's done it what have i
said about bernie sanders you've given
him a shout out
i've said bernie sanders is a true
believer and i respect true believers
even though i may disagree with you
i respect true believers that's why i
got to give a true believer yeah and
that's why i got to give another shout
out to bill maher he will have
he will have the right to let the other
i mean the most famous
one of the most famous clips he had is
he had and and coulter come on and she
predicted trump
and everyone laughed at her and she sat
there with her smug devilish look and
she turned out to be right so just one
added observation about that
it there used to be constant debate when
i was on 2020 we would do a story you
would always go to the other side and
have a debate
and they had crossfire on cable
by the time i left 2020 because they
just
were not libertarian sympathetic anymore
and went to fox i assumed i was going to
have good debates
with o'reilly and sean hannity about my
libertarian issues
drug legalization opposition to
tariffs what are some of the other ones
but after one they didn't want to fight
with me either
who didn't hannity and o'reilly and if
you look at cable now
nobody is fighting they're either they
either have a guest where they just
trash but most of it is people agreeing
and saying yep yeah they're evil evil i
i have to
completely agree with john sauce here
because this is my note right here
regarding parlor
on one side of the of the spectrum you
have echo chambers
and like parlor i believe is sort of an
echo chamber you're just speaking to the
people who already believe with you
versus something that i know you're a
huge proponent of is having open debates
something that you
are very passionate about of having you
know you've done marijuana debates and
you've done
vaccination debates and i know that's
something that you wholeheartedly
believe in
but i feel like that's the problem now
even like the whole point of
valuetainment and the whole point of the
pbd podcast
is to have an open dialogue and uh i
don't agree with you on that pat you're
wrong here like even you guys have
disagreed a few times but you can have i
think some i think the the
the catch phrases you can disagree
without being disagreeable
and you're all about debates are you not
oh i think listen any great family that
produce great leaders you will
if you ask the kids what did your
parents do to you growing up they'll say
we were forced to debate every night
any great family that produced kids that
became great leaders
it was a debate environment you're
constantly saying so what do you think
about what do you think about drugs
should it be legal no dad why would it
be equal why should it not be illegal
why should not be and then you would go
back and forth kennedys would do this
it's it's a tradition amongst some of
the
families that produce i think debate is
missing i think the reason why dana
white is killing it is because it's a
format of a debate
it's a fight i think the reason why this
dumb
whatever this fight the most pathetic
fight i've seen in my life the show was
embarrassing tom and his wife kimmel
were like dude just go home i feel like
i'm watching soft porn right now
the kids are running around with this
fight and all these different the only
person that was doing some stuff was
ice cube came and rocked a couple songs
that was good justin bieber was kind of
funny and then the other guy
david's uh um pete davidson was a
trainer
what happened to you right you just yeah
you're burning money just because you
can but people paid millions paid to
watch the 50
show so the true idiots are the ones
that pay the 50 bucks if you really
think about it right
but what's the point you know you know
why i did well because it's a form of a
debate of course
it's a form of a debate we need more
debate
i got a challenge for uh media i think
the media needs to hire the next william
buckley
i think they need to bring someone who
brings a complete to opposite sides
in the same room if they don't want to
do it for free
pay to their charity if they still don't
want to do it pay to them
and i think eventually when you're
paying them the money they finally will
say fine i'll do it because if there's
ever been a time to compete with cnn fox
and msnbc
or anybody else abc your best friends if
you go and
go against any of these guys today's the
time to do it because everyone's playing
it
so safe because i don't want to offend
john nor do i want to offend
adam i just want to keep my atom fan
happy
and it does keep the atom fans happy
and that's they're these they're stupid
in so many ways
yeah they often they are they're so good
they're not stupid about this
they see what works minute by minute and
debates today
don't work it's also hard to get debates
i do it on stossel tv but we call
40 teachers unions to get a spokesperson
for the teachers unions they don't just
don't want to talk to the other side
well you know who does i got i got to
give this guy some credit and i know you
you've done a segment with him as this
guy stephen crowder he'll go on to
campuses
and he'll put up a table and a chair and
and say
you know the point of the day tell me
why i'm wrong and have open
forum debates and you get unedited
unedited
so you had a chance to sit down with him
and tell not sit down but you know
zoom out your last episode is let
crowder speak i think it's your video
that you did
tell us about that he
had his father is his booker
and his father took the job because he
kept hiring bookers
and they said nobody wants to go on your
show
and his father was able to get people to
come on the show
and he's become very successful he's got
he's got the biggest conservative
youtube
outlet and his father says look
the youtube is killing our stuff he's
taking it off it's demonetizing us
we're just not running it at all what's
the content
so i look at it and it's political
content that ought to be on he
he found that some people in nevada who
voted
voted from phony addresses it was
genuine investigative reporting and he
posted sources
but youtube because they're so
overreacting to the
trump worried that he wouldn't leave
office or that the election was fixed
they have this policy you can't even
have any discussions about election
fraud that suggests
an election was stolen so they just ban
it
and i thought that was wrong we looked
at some of his other
jokes he's funny sometimes some of it
felt mean had made me cringe i told him
that
that pissed him off but that's my video
last week so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you